good to see you all bright and early to
talk about data contracts
all right let's just uh let's just get
right into it
um so a little about me a little bit
about me uh I'm Chad
I run a slot Community these days called
Data quality Camp it has about 5 000
people we talk about how you do data
quality at scale if you want to join
it's free there's a link at the bottom
there just data quality Camp good
dataquality.camp backslash slack
prior to that I was doing uh working on
the AI platform team over at Microsoft
so we supported a lot of the big data
and ml initiatives at Microsoft and then
most recently I spent uh three years at
Convoy which is a digital Freight
technology platform
and uh I was leading the data platform
team over there
uh convolu is very different from
Microsoft as you can expect it was a
more of a a late stage startup about
series D had around 12 1300 people
around uh five or six hundred person uh
engineering team
and what I originally joined to do
was build the data platform team
essentially from the ground up and
specifically I was I had a a focus on
machine learning and experimentation
that's really what Convoy cared about
their business was built on top of ML
and routing and batching and a lot of
cool algorithm oriented Freight
challenges
and helping develop some of those
interesting applications of AI and ml
and essentially running those systems at
scale
uh here's what I actually did
um
endless firefighting from day one right
that was not fun in fact I I left
Microsoft because this is essentially
what I was doing all the time and I
assumed that at a startup it would be
different it was not
my team was responsible for maintaining
some of the messiest sequel I've ever
seen in my life
um hundreds of lines of SQL
in certain Legacy tables
and the amount of code was growing not
lessening
we had a pretty poor relationships with
our customers unfortunately as an
infrastructure team this is a really
challenging place to be because you're
not directly impacting bottom line
revenue so you have to rely on your
stakeholders to give you you know thumbs
up and praise and all that stuff and we
were just constantly at odds with our
consumers
and then uh I I was essentially trying
to consistently hire more data engineers
and repeatedly getting turned down uh
because I couldn't justify the spin to
our executive team that was fun
um so I did not like existing in that
state of the world and I wanted to solve
that problem
and so there were a few core issues that
I observed and I wanted to tackle them
one by one
the first one is that we were
experiencing essentially constant
failures whether these were breaking
pipeline changes caused by Upstream
teams or more Insidious issues where
stuff wouldn't outright fail but the
underlying business logic would change
so if you you can imagine that a column
called shipment distance in miles that's
essentially meant to express miles gets
changed to kilometers and nobody knows
about that and that fundamentally
changes a lot of the predictions of the
models Downstream
Huges huge amounts of data replication
we have the same metric and the same
Dimension repeated quite literally
dozens in some cases hundreds of times
that is not an exaggeration we also had
a lot of alerts and a lot of tests so we
certainly just it's not like we weren't
doing any data quality at all we were
encouraging all of our consumers to
write tests it's just those tests were
firing constantly and there was no real
solution in place there was no one to
say like hey a test failed now I'm going
to go figure out what caused it and
there's actually going to be a
resolution in place and this led to
fatigue people just started ignoring
these alerts because they weren't being
resolved in a timely fashion
um on-call extraordinarily painful for
all the reasons above and I already
mentioned bad relationships
okay so
um root causes
uh I spent about a quarter digging into
the root causes of these issues
um the first one I found was a lack of
visibility
and what I mean by that is that both the
data producer and the data consumer
we're not aware of each other so the
data producers were essentially
completely had a lot of first party data
they were maintaining transactional
databases
um those transactional databases were
supporting their you know applications
and their features and all these other
cool things
um but they were never intended to
support machine learning and analytics
and so when changes would happen like
let's say columns would get dropped or
column names would change nobody the the
the producer would not know who they
were impacting uh by that chain so they
were essentially operating in the dark
oh we're leveraging Snowflake and
snowflake was in all for all intents and
purposes of black box
the data consumers on the other hand had
no visibility into what changes were
causing the problems that they were
experiencing so they knew they were
having data quality issues you know they
would start to see data change out from
underneath them sometimes their
pipelines would break but but they just
didn't know what caused it and their
primary point of contact was was me it
was a data engineering team and so
that's why we got this flood of requests
and service tickets essentially
endlessly just because they didn't know
who else to blame for some of those
issues and so therefore we became a
bottleneck and basically no team in the
company understood how other teams were
were affecting each other
uh second Bruce cause was uh pipeline
evolution
we didn't really have a good method of
iteratively evolving our pipelines over
time both as our Upstream changes
happened or as the underlying business
logic uh changed so we started seeing a
lot more complex filtering being added
on top of SQL basically to account for
those changes
um that made the sequel very very
difficult to interpret and parse for
anyone that wasn't writing the code so
when someone new came around and they're
like oh I want to understand how we're
calculating margin at Convoy and they
were hit with this 800 line monstrosity
they would just say I'm not going to
spend my time trying to de-parse this I
will just go talk to the engineer
understand what the raw data is and then
build my own table and that's what led
to the duplication so it was a lack of
trust in the code that people were
writing and they said I'll just build my
own stuff and then when you have five or
six or seven different versions of the
same query that causes a totally
different problem it causes a cost
problem and other issues as well
the third root cause was a lack of
ownership or a lack of governance I
guess you could say so like I mentioned
before the data producers didn't really
own the data that they were emitting
it's at least in the sense that we data
people actually care about
um and so when things would break they'd
basically say hey look we never signed
up to to care about these issues so why
should we
um and then due to the second point you
know because we have this sort of
spiraling spaghetti Sequel and all this
other stuff we saw huge numbers of obts
or basically one big table where people
would just say look I I really don't
know what this stuff is I don't want to
maintain it myself I'm just gonna stick
my column that I care about on top of
this existing table that somebody else
owns and that would happen over and over
and over and over again until the
underlying table itself like nobody
really understood exactly what it was
and nobody was was willing or able to
take ownership over it
and so our highest value data sets in
the company like our machine learning
models
um we had metrics that were being piped
into react dashboards and shown to
customers all of that was built
leveraging tables that were like
fundamentally not owned by anyone and so
when something eventually broke and it
inevitably did no one was raising their
hand to fix it and so again all of these
issues were routed to the data
engineering team
um so there's a root cause for a root
cause here and I wanted to understand
that's a pretty unfortunate state of the
world and how how do we get here this is
essentially how data evolved at Convoy
um our our v0 so to speak was pure
product so Dan and Grant who started
Convoy they were going out and talking
to truckers at truck stops and saying I
want to build an application that works
for them uh they didn't care about about
the data it was not their prerogative it
was only features and only early
services and next we started caring a
lot more about customer acquisition
things like marketing and sales and you
know a customer experience around the
product came after that and data here
primarily served the function of a
support mechanism right how much churn
do we have over the last 30 days
um how many people are using X feature
that type of thing and with this type of
data it could be wrong essentially it
was okay for it to be directional it's
just that teams needed it very very fast
but as we continued down this curve
towards you know oh now we actually need
to focus on margin optimization we need
to build machine learning models we need
to have better operational efficiency
and finally we're starting to get
regulated by the government this is
where data actually become became
incredibly important and accuracy became
incredibly important as well
and so the the takeaway that I had is
that when you're just getting started
the data team is a support function and
data quality isn't really worth the ROI
it's better to move fast move quickly
not really think about scale it's okay
to be directional you have a small team
and that's sort of where we were for a
large number of years but then the
problem is once you hit scale that
initial set of pipelines that worked
before to solve the support problem
doesn't work when you're trying to solve
a high value product problem or when
you're starting to get regulated or when
you're starting to leverage machine
learning
so that data infrastructure becomes a
massive massive cost you're hiring lots
of people you're hiring data engineers
and business intelligence engineers and
analysts and whatever else and you have
to justify that spend and now that
directional data not acceptable you need
to have high levels of accuracy we had
machine learning models where we would
report on the ETA of any shipment and a
shipper would look at every every piece
of data and say okay well I'm going to
use this to ensure that I have the right
number of operations members staffed at
the facility at that time so it couldn't
be wrong right if if we are wrong that
means the customer is wrong and that's
going to come back on Convoy so accuracy
is very high
data quality is becomes a necessity it's
not a nice to have at this point
so when you think about that curve the
business curve you can also frame it as
a curve of use cases for data and on one
end of the curve you have what I would
call like a prototype use case so these
are things it's like it's okay to be ad
hoc it's okay for there to be some
directionality and then on the far end
you have the production use case right
financial reporting is obviously the
thing that needs to be as close to 100
correct as humanly possible AIML same
thing and depending on where your
business is it's going to require a
different architecture
so the high level summary here is that
you've got data support and you've got
data as product data support quick and
Scrappy really important to have early
on you've got to be able to move quickly
doesn't require a ton of complexity you
can do it with a small team and data as
a product needs a little bigger team
really important much later on it can
generate Roi all on its own it's
expensive uh but also extremely valuable
okay so uh Convoy was using the modern
data stack and hopefully
um I'm sort of preaching the choir and
modern datastack is awesome and we all
love it so we're using you know DBT
airflow 5tran Tableau this was basically
our our stack that what's on the screen
here
um and this is this is awesome when
you're trying to move fast right when
you're getting set up it's super easy to
just plug these tools into a postgres
database you know pipe pipe some data in
do some relatively minimal checks do
some data modeling make it very
accessible to the entire team and so on
and so forth but like you've just seen
once you start getting to scale that
speed gets a little bit tougher so there
are some pros and cons to the modern
data stack uh Pros are self-service very
easy to learn right it's all SQL it's
python it's stuff that most uh data
analysts and data Engineers know off the
bat
easy to implement and not very expensive
from the beginning but the cons are not
a lot of great ownership uh this garbage
in garbage out problem there's not an
awesome solution for it usually you have
any you know analysts and data Engineers
dealing with the garbage and like
fundamentally that doesn't scale too
well
um you get a huge buildup of tech debt
you don't have a ton of contexts on what
the data actually means this is why you
see sort of this influx and excitement
about data catalogs
um and obviously you are lacking of
quality in most cases
so at a very high level this is kind of
what our architecture looked like
obviously I'm simplifying it but we had
operational use cases we stored that in
uh in postgres and in MySQL databases
we were doing uh both regular sort of
batch extractions of that data using
5tran and we also had a CDC using
dibesium via Kafka and we were piping
that into a data Lake and from there it
was flowing into snowflake then we were
leveraging DBT to do all of our data
modeling and then it would get piped
into Tableau and machine learning and
all those other really great things
but you can obviously see
uh in the step that's moving the data
from our databases into where we're
actually uh storing our data and doing
analysis if things change there if the
data producer decides to drop a column
if they decide maybe they want to
completely you know decompose that
particular service or decompose a
monolith everything Downstream breaks
and this is the problem that I mentioned
before leads to what I call
non-consensual apis meaning essentially
we were treating our data as an API but
no one had agreed officially that this
was an API and it needed slas
and that caused the entire pipeline to
essentially be structure the exact same
way all the way down to our tables that
people were taking a dependency on so
folks were constructing DBT models and
saying well look this person who is
above me where I'm extracting the data
from them they don't have a contract
there's no API so why should I be
willing to give it to someone else and
this is fundamentally what caused our
problems around ownership
okay so um high level definitions let's
talk about data as a product what that
means
um my opinion is that data ownership
essentially just looks like following
software engineering best practices it's
CI CD Version Control API development
having great monitoring things like that
I know there's a lot of different terms
for data products
I feel that a data product is the
equivalent of an engineering product but
for data and that means that data
quality meaning if things break there's
some responsibility to fit to fix them
and treat them as a production bug is
everybody's responsibility it's not just
on the onus of the data engineering team
and the data analysts
data consumers and producers need to
talk in the same way that software
Engineers talk with each other through
tools like GitHub they do code review
they look at code diffs there needs to
be something similar sort of operating
at the level of the data
there needs to be some sort of common
standards of doing engineering for data
and the business has to acknowledge
those and sort of improve them over time
and then if you have a data product
meaning something that is generating
value for the company or something that
requires a level of compliance that it
is supported by a production grade
Pipeline and not a pipeline that is
solely designed to move quickly
um how do you actually do that uh this
is something that I've said uh
relatively frequently at Convoy which is
that a verbal contract isn't worth the
paper it's written on yes I think it's
not a bad thing to start with verbal
agreements between teams or agreements
that are written down on a piece of
paper that says hey these are our
expectations and I would really really
really love it if you didn't break us
but unfortunately as I'm sure a lot of
you know that's just not reality right
as soon as uh it becomes like really
challenging to prioritize between the
data and whatever features somebody
cares about no no one cares about these
types of agreements anymore and once
someone stops caring once it's a lot
easier to ignore it the next time
all right so uh data contracts right 15
10 15 minutes and we're finally getting
to the core of the topic here
um
data contracts are API based agreements
between data producers and data
consumers
and it captures what are the
expectations of the data including the
schema the semantics distributions slas
really anything about the data that is
Meaningful for that data product
they are the technical vehicle that is
required to implement and Safeguard data
products
um there's a few really cool things that
data contracts are supposed to do the
first is provide a a shared language
which I think is the language of English
or whatever country you are from
um it allows the data model to evolve in
an iterative way so instead of doing a
massive refactor one year waiting until
all the data fundamentally changes and
the business changes and the Upstream
Services changes and then doing a
refactor again you're doing it piece by
piece by piece
and it's about an incremental data
governance versus massive organizational
shifts
so here's in practice what a contract
could look like
um like I said the contract itself at
Convoy we represented these as yaml
files but it really could be anything
it's supposed to be agnostic and generic
to the underlying technology
um it can include anything here I
recommend starting with the schema first
because that's the easiest to enforce
and it's also the best to just get
people especially your Upstream
producers aware of how the data is
impacting their consumers and once that
awareness exists you can begin layering
on more complex checks over time things
like semantics uh cardinality looking at
uh the values of the data like we have a
column called you know customer ID
that's always supposed to be a 10
character string
and those types of things
and then there needs to be some type of
validation task that's running at the
right level of the pipeline to determine
if the constraints described in the
contract are actually met or not
and then there needs to be some feedback
loop back to whoever owns the contract
to say hey there's been a violation
there's now a thing that you can you
need to fix or on the opposite side
you're about to make a change that will
break the contract you probably
shouldn't do that
um
oh looks looks like a duplicated slide
there so the way that we think about uh
I think about contracts is sort of split
into two parts there's a preventative
piece and there's a
a piece around detection
um prevention obviously is about
stopping problems before they happen so
this is getting inserted into the cicd
workflow is being able to enforce
schemas and values at a high level the
way that we did that
um there's sort of a much more complex
detailed architecture that I would be
happy to talk about but the the high
level is we had a a githubot that would
comment on PRS with context about what
was being broken if some schema was
changed Upstream the next level of that
is we actually uh would just break cicd
if someone was making a change that
violated the contract those contracts
are stored in a schema registry
and then we also had checks at the
application code level so if we detected
in that you know 10 character string
example I mentioned before that
something was being violated we would
just fire an exception and then point
them to the contract and say hey like
here's why this issue happened
um lineage really really important the
big goal of contracts in the
preventative stage at least early on is
to be a feedback loop you don't want to
be a wall and say like okay I'm just
going to break everything what you want
is for the producer to talk to the
consumer and say wait you know maybe I
shouldn't push this change out at you
know 4 30 p.m on a Friday if I know that
it's going to break a really meaningful
machine learning model at the company
instead what I want to do is wait until
Monday and then maybe just have a
meeting with them and like figure out
the sort of best way to iterate moving
forward
and then on the detection piece uh this
is this is essentially monitoring and
observability right so it's like
detecting when things are going wrong
trying to push that detection as far
left as close to the producer as you
possibly can it's really really hard to
get someone to take action on something
if you're only alerting them like four
days after it's actually happened you
want it to be in there as close to as
close to their workflow as possible so
at Convoy we had alerts that were set up
in the Stream processing layer using
Flink if we detected that there was a
violation of the contract using CDC we
would just shunt that off to a doq and
we would immediately send feedback to
the engineer like hey something failed
go take a look at this
and then also all of these monitors are
supposed to
um capture the SLA and ideally you can
report back on that SLA so you can
describe very clearly here are the
violations that we had here's what we
expected to happen here's what our data
product needs to be successful and
therefore here is the data quality score
for our particular data product with all
the root causes for why that score has
gone down
um so I've kind of talked about the what
this is the how I've sort of described
it at a at a relatively high level we
were storing all of our contracts at
least for schemas and the Costco schema
registry it's open source it's also
totally generic you don't have to be
doing streaming in order to store
contracts in the schema registry it has
a lot of valuable properties to it
um we would then implement the contracts
at least in our production systems uh
using using protobuf
um but you know this is you can use
really any registry or you can use any
type of uh schema serialization
framework you can use Avro you could use
Json if you didn't want to use a Kafka
schema registry you could just use
GitHub for that and it also works
totally fine and then
um as you're as a software engineer or
whoever is the data producer is going
through the CI CD process they go
through build they go through test then
you have a check that checks the schema
compatibility if the if there is no
backwards compatibility if that check
fails then you can either break the
build or you can just fire an alert and
saying hey you're about to break
something and you can include ideally
all of that lineage data and context
about what is being broken
um so this is kind of what I just ran
through right the contracts are stored
in a registry they run during CI CD we
use column level lineage in order to
provide context to our producers we were
using uh
um
we had a sort of a custom API that we
built where essentially a data consumer
could specify like hey here's the
lineage for a pipeline that I care about
the data is going flowing from a and
going to B and here's sort of the file
um
and then we would uh add metadata Fields
um in a yaml file where the consumer
would essentially specify you know
here's how this data is actually being
used this is a machine learning model if
this fails it's a step zero or it's a
Sev one it's going to cost the company
fifty thousand dollars a day or whatever
it might be someone's gonna have to wake
up in the middle of the night and go
solve this problem uh and therefore when
something changed Upstream that was
going to break that data product which
we would analyze through the lineage we
would drop all that context to them
through a GitHub bot
um like I mentioned uh we had semantic
checks uh checks that were running in
the Stream processing layer and then we
also had checks on the distributions of
the data that would run in in Snowflake
we were doing sort of data profiles
um and this this all works for batch as
well
um obviously like there's some checks
that you can't do in batch versus a
streaming system but conceptually it's
all the same stuff you still have a
schema registry you still have a set of
constraints there's just different
actions that you would take in batch so
for us if we detected that there was
like some batch violation we would just
like roll back to a previous version of
the data model
oh and then we were using a catalog so I
think uh I think Mark from stemo is
going to be speaking later but we were
using we were using the open source
Amazon for this and then we eventually
moved to stima
uh okay so
um how do you actually go about
implementing something like this at your
company well the answer is you don't do
it all at once uh because you will get
pushed back this is a very New Concept
and it requires a lot of change and so
starting small and you're working your
way up is the right way of doing it
awareness is the first and most
important step and this is essentially
just helping people understand giving
them that visibility that I make a
change here's what I'm going to impact
and as a consumer someone made a change
and here's how it impacted me and in
that way you're abstracting a lot of the
infrastructure and data engineering
teams from that problem you're giving a
you get basically providing the
consumers with a vehicle to escalate
their problems directly to the team that
caused them
ownership is next so this is the actual
contract right this is sort of the the
the the the actual piece of code that
prevents things from from breaking
um and this is sort of at least what I
found was that the engineers naturally
wanted this over time once they realized
that they had a lot of important
dependencies they're like well yeah I
would actually just like not like to
have to think about this stuff
um and then the next level is the API or
abstractions
um so in one of the ways that we were
using Flink was essentially saying hey
software Engineers instead of having to
go and like talk to your consumers every
single time you're making a change why
don't you just use an abstraction layer
um like I said we provided Flink they
could query their database they could
vend all the details of the contract to
their consumers and then they could
change their databases however they want
and not think about it which was great
um and then the last step is the actual
rules so the long tail of constraints
value checks checks on distributions
etc etc et cetera this really only comes
once the producer is comfortable with
taking ownership of the data and it's
probably a larger org level conversation
but the good thing is is that if you've
if you followed the previous three steps
then everybody in the entire value chain
thinks that this is a must-have not a
nice to have and what you're actually
negotiating is like how much do we want
to do how how much resources should we
spend on this not like should we do this
at all
um so the old world is on the left right
you've got non-consensual apis and
stuff's breaking and everybody's unhappy
and then on the right you've got
contracts this sort of beautiful new
idyllic world where you've got contracts
between production systems and your data
warehouse and there's some expectation
in place that is also a check in that
way both the producers and consumers are
doing their diligence
and then on the actual data product
itself you have a expectation
um so what are the some of the
incentives for the Upstream teams to
actually do this uh well one like I
mentioned before is just having
awareness of I would say 100 of the
engineers that I know don't want to
deliberately break people if they are
told hey like this change that you're
making is going to you know break our
machine learning model and through which
100 million dollars uh flows through
every year they probably won't do that
without talking to someone
um
or at the very least you're providing
them with context that helps them make
trade-offs and sort of balance those
decisions uh it's also simplicity so all
the tools that I described are generally
a part of the the tool chain they
already use right GitHub Kafka if
they're using Kafka you know you could
use uh in any other form of sort of Pub
sub model or streaming system it doesn't
really matter
um and then protobuf Avro you know Json
all of these are things that Engineers
are very familiar with conceptually it's
also very familiar with Engineers as
well really what we're talking about
here is integration testing right CI CD
and apis those are all like very obvious
Concepts
um and it's also increasing their value
as well so instead of just doing work
like throwing data that is nonsense and
not particularly useful into a
transactional system it was very
eye-opening for a lot of the engineers
at Convoy like holy cow I'm at like this
stuff that I thought was nothing is
actually like powering a dashboard that
the CEO looks at every single morning
that's just a really cool and and uh
insightful thing for them
but the the key point and I just want to
call this out I kind of said it a bit
before but I'll say it again
um data contracts are not for all of
your data right they're for the data
that really really matters and it's for
the data products that are adding
business value to your company that
makes the sell to leadership much easier
instead of taking this generic
application of data quality and saying I
want this layer of quality and
governance across my entire Warehouse
you're saying I want quality and
governance for these very particular
pipelines and ideally you can even track
how much business value in terms of
money that level of quality has and this
is exactly what happened at Convoy we
had uh our first application of
contracts was our pricing model
about 30 35
of all the data that flowed into our
training set had to get thrown out due
to no values and we use contracts to
essentially prove we could reduce that
number thereby making the model more
accurate thereby making Convoy more
money
um so like I said where where do you
start find the most critical use cases
um if your company cares about data
those use cases probably exist
um I've I've talked to you know hundreds
of folks at this point that have use
cases just like this and there's a
massive range is everything from
accounting to uses-based pricing price
usage based pricing pipelines to machine
learning models to metrics embedded in
applications to all sorts of other
interesting things start there start
where the money is and then gradually
expand outwards
um the data contract is not meant to be
just in one place in the pipeline it
should be at every place in the pipeline
there are some meaningful transformation
step or a handoff of a producer to a
consumer
um once that pipe once the contract
exists through the pipeline this is what
I I refer to as a production grade data
pipeline right it's scalable it's backed
by CI CD it's following engineering best
practices demonstrate the robustness and
then roll out to the rest of the
business
um so where you start it your the
primary focus in the beginning is on
data quality or awareness and saving
money
um as you start to iterate you know the
the contract is very very flexible so
what we began to see was a focus on on
data modeling adding in those layers of
abstraction adding in more detailed and
comprehensive alerts and monitors and
then where you end up is a solution for
data governance and privacy policy
enforcement and compliance
um since you have that lineage piece in
place it is a bi-directional contract so
in the same way that you can ensure that
the data flowing from one location to
another location is the right data you
can also ensure the data from flowing
from one location to the right location
is only being used in the locations that
it should be
but that's a presentation for another
day
um in terms of impact at Convoy we
rolled out hundreds of these
um really really major impacts to the
bottom line it was one of the the
largest initiatives for all of an
infrastructure just in terms of Roi
um my personal largest accomplishment
doing this was that the producers and
consumers started talking to each other
we had uh threads and slack that were 50
60 messages long of software Engineers
going back and forth with data
scientists about like what the data
needed to look like and that was not
something that ever happened before all
of that went to data engineering and we
essentially completely abstracted
ourselves so that was really really cool
um we also had way better documentation
and the reason why is there was actually
an incentive for the data teams to
create good documentation right because
if you want something enforced a
particular way you have to describe what
the data is and so you're you're truly
you're actually incentivizing uh data
teams to provide good documentation to
Engineers who validate it and then that
documentation then Cascades throughout
the whole pipeline
uh so key takeaways
um data contracts data apis they support
data products they cover Steve and
semantics and a whole bunch of other
really cool stuff
um
really critical in my opinion to uh
doing data product development in
general if you're moving to a
decentralized system where you're trying
to abstract away the data Engineers
maybe there's another way to do it that
doesn't involve uh contracts I can't
personally think of what that is uh
maybe some of you will come up and and
educate me uh uh and uh and and again
the goal is to invest where you get
iterative incremental value start small
they don't need to be applied everywhere
only focus on use cases where you're
actually adding business value
all right we've got we've got two
minutes and 30 seconds left I'm done
um
thank you
[Music]